sifflé et hué à la sortie du directeur
général de la police nationale hier jean
marc falcone était pourtant venu à evry
pour appeler à l'apaisement
ils ont dit maintenant dit jean-marc
falcone démission non il y a hier
entendu monsieur ministre cieux
laissez-moi aller au bout de mon ventre
et on a entendu non par l évidence il
n'a pas été entendu
un fonctionnaire s'est même jeté sous
ses roues pour le forcer à descendre de
son véhicule comprend pas c'est leur la
démonstration de cette émotion quand la
police nationale ne peut pas se
permettre dans le contexte au plus que
nous vivons actuellement à vivre ce
genre d'événement aujourd'hui chacun se
croit tout permis
il est vraiment grand temps de rétablir
l'autorité de l'état
si j'ai accepté que l'on saisisse
l'inspection générale de la police
nationale
c'est pas pour entrer dans un cycle de
sanctions c'est pour rappeler des
principes par certes la loi doit être
respectée et bien sûr par tout le monde
mais leur exaspération aujourd'hui
atteint un degré tel que les pouvoirs
publics doivent réagir
les policiers en france aujourd'hui ont
peur ils ont peur parce que
ils sont pas en sécurité parce que ceux
qui les agressent ne sont pas
suffisamment puni par la justice
le front national aujourd'hui
n'intervient quasiment sûr chien même si
nous avons vu sa patte ou sam aurait pas
de pattes du front national il ya un vif
soutien ça c'est évident un soutien sans
faille du fond national prix n'ont plus
d'arguments et la seule chose qu'ils
trouvent dans leurs vieux placard à
balais c'est la mise en cause du front
national oui tant mieux si c'est vrai
que les policiers sont avec nous on
n'est pas obligé de politiser tous ces
problèmes on peut regarder les problèmes
en face ça c'est le rôle des
responsables publics d'un homme d'état
rien le conseil municipal j'ai par
robert ménard a été quelque peu
perturbée des réfugiés doivent en effet
être hébergés dans les centres d'accueil
à béziers ce que refuse robert ménard
partir il a été lu en étant soutenu par
le front national
voilà une dette envers un développement
voire des ratios d'endettement
soi-disant fallacieux une épargne nette
négative et surtout un emprunt qualifiés
de fictifs
voilà ce qui fait dire à l'élu
socialiste matthieu rouveyre que le
maire de bordeaux dissimule une
situation financière explosive
manipulation politique il n'ya pas
évidemment de déficit caché et je le
répète la lettre que le préfet m'a
envoyé est totalement explicite sur ce
plan là donc je suis très serein
la surprise politique du jour cécile
duflot éliminé au premier tour de la
primaire écologiste
nous menons nos investigations pendant
des mois et en l'occurrence la raison en
2008 128 euros puisque ailleurs monsieur
estrosi jeu vous permet pas de dire avec
beaucoup de médiocrité on vous respecte
vous êtes chassé comme un pokémon rare
dans la campagne de la primaire tout vu
mais s'est étonné la question c'est pas
ce n'est pas qu'esthétique